fuel costs have been very high this
winter for millions of Americans but
spare a thought for a moment for
families in the UK where the average
Energy bill has nearly doubled and it's
forcing many people
just to save money to turn to so-called
warm Banks all in an effort to stay warm
through these cold months Charlie
Daggett visited one on a busy site here
in West London
at first glance it looks and sounds
[Music]
like any after-school Club
but these families have gathered for
more than fun and games they came just
to keep warm if only for a few hours
like most people in Britain Emma Harper
has seen her heating bill triple this
year I used to stress about it but the
last month I haven't even been stressing
because what can I do I've got two small
children exactly and these houses are
really really cold there's a really bad
draft my son's room it's got really bad
damp black mold all over the wall from
the outside walls she already owes more
than twelve hundred dollars so how
important is it to have a place like
this oh it's really good that to know
that there is somewhere where you if you
need it you can come and get warm get a
hot meal let the kids play once a week
Our Lady Fatima Church in London opens
its doors to everyone needing a warm
space and maybe a warm meal so families
don't have to eat the home between
school time and bedtime
hosted by part-time cook and full-time
priest Father Richard Nesbitt of course
this is a response to the cost of living
crisis but in the way that we've done it
we've absolutely tried to do everything
we can
to make it not feel like a charity
project
program of local councils charities and
businesses providing a little help with
places like libraries bakeries even
theaters and Opera Houses opening their
doors in fact there are nearly 4 000
so-called warm Banks spread across the
country like this church in West London
a crisis so severe countless households
will be forced to choose today between
Heating and eating average annual energy
bills have surged 96 percent this year
to roughly three thousand dollars and
soaring prices have coincided with
plummeting temperatures with temps 35 to
40 degrees lower than average hovering
below freezing for days
double-digit inflation and the global
energy crisis due in part to the war in
Ukraine has hit Britain especially hard
but the initiative has been seen
simultaneously as ingenious and
horrifying that millions of people in
one of the top 10 richest countries in
the world should be struggling just to
stay warm which is why Father Richard
and his volunteers do what they can to
remove the stigma of a heating handout I
mean the warmth that you feel when you
come in here is not about the central
heating absolutely it's about the warmth
of the welcome it's the the love in the
cooking the fun in the games just a
chance for those who need a little help
to come in from the cold
for CBS mornings Charlie dagada London